[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hi
i'm neil schusterman and i'm going to be
reading chapter 4
of coraline by neil gaiman
the house looked exactly the same from
the outside
or almost exactly the same around miss
[ __ ] and miss forcible's door
were blue and red light bulbs that
flashed on and off spelling out words
the lights chasing each other around the
door
on and off around and around astounding
was followed by a theatrical and then
triumph it was a sunny cold day
exactly like the one she'd left there
was a polite noise from behind her
she turned around standing on the wall
next to her was a large black
cat identical to the large black cat
she's seen in the grounds at home
good afternoon said the cat its voice
sounded like the voice of the back of
coraline's head
the voice she thought words in but a
man's voice not a girl's
hello said coraline i saw a cat like you
in the garden at home you must be the
other cat
the cat shook its head no it said
i'm not the other anything i'm me
it tipped its head to one side green
eyes glinted
you people are spread all over the place
cats on the other hand keep ourselves
together
if you see what i mean i suppose
but if you're the same cat i saw at home
how can you talk
cats don't have shoulders not like
people do but the cat shrugged in one
smooth movement that started at the tip
of its tail and
ended in a raised movement of its
whiskers
i can talk cats don't talk at home
no said the cat no said coraline
the cat leaped smoothly from the wall to
the grass near coraline's feet
it stared up at her well you're the
expert on these things
said the cat dryly after all what would
i know
i'm only a cat it began to walk away
head and tail held high and proud come
back
said coraline please i'm sorry i really
am
the cat stopped walking sat down and
began to wash itself thoroughly
apparently unaware of coraline's
existence
we we could be friends you know said
coraline
we could be rare specimens of an exotic
breed of african dancing elephants
said the cat but we're not at least
it added cataly after darting a brief
look at coraline
i'm not coraline's side
please what's your name coraline as the
cat
look i'm coraline okay the cat yawned
slowly
carefully revealing a mouth and tongue
of astounding pinkness
cats don't have names it said no
said coraline no said the cat
now you people have names that's because
you don't know who you are
we know who we are so we don't need
names
there was something irritatingly
self-centered about the cat
coraline decided as if it were in its
opinion
the only thing in any world or place
that could possibly be of any importance
half of her wanted to be very rude to it
the other half of her wanted to be
polite and deferential
the polite half won please
what is this place the cat glanced
around
briefly it's here said the cat
i can see that well how did you get here
like you did i walked said the cat
like this coraline watched as the cat
walked slowly across the lawn
it walked behind the tree but didn't
come out the other side
coraline went over to the tree and
looked behind it the cat was gone
she walked back toward the house there
was another polite noise from behind her
it was the cat by the by it said
it was sensible of you to bring
protection i'd hang onto it if i were
you
protection that's what i said said the
cat
and anyway it paused and stared intently
at something that wasn't there
then it went down into a low crouch and
moved slowly forward
two or three steps it seemed to be
stalking an invisible mouse
abruptly it turned tail and dashed for
the woods
it vanished among the trees
coraline wondered what the cat had meant
she also wondered whether cats could all
talk where she came from and just chose
not to
or whether they could only talk when
they were here wherever here was
she walked down the brick steps to the
mrs [ __ ] and forcible's front door
the blue and red lights flashed on and
off
the door was open just slightly she
knocked on it
but her first knock made the door swing
open and coraline went in
she was in a dark room that smelled of
dust and velvet
the door swung shut behind her and the
room was black
coraline edged forward into a small ante
room
her face brushed against something soft
it was cloth
she reached up her hand and pushed at
the cloth it parted
she stood blinking on the other side of
the velvet curtains in a poorly lit
theater far away at the edge of the room
was a high wooden stage empty and bare
a dim spotlight shining onto it from
high above
there were seats between coraline in the
stage rows and rows of seats
she heard a shuffling noise and a light
came toward her swinging from side to
side
when it was closer she saw the light was
coming from a flashlight being carried
in the mouth of a large black skydog
its muzzle gray with age hello said
coraline
the dog put the flashlight down on the
floor and looked up at her
right let's see your ticket he said
gruffly
ticket that's what i said ticket i
haven't got all day you know
you can't watch the show without a
ticket coraline sighed
i don't have a ticket she admitted
another one said the dog gloomily
come in here bold as anything where's
your ticket haven't got one
i don't know it shook its head then
shrugged
come on then he picked up the flashlight
in his mouth and trotted off into the
dark
coraline followed him when he got near
the front of the stage he stopped and
shone the flashlight onto an empty seat
coraline sat down and the dog wandered
off
as her eyes got used to the darkness she
realized that the other inhabitants of
the seats were also dogs
there was a sudden hissing noise from
behind the stage
coraline decided it was the sound of a
scratchy old record being put onto a
record player
the hissing became the noise of trumpets
and miss [ __ ] and miss forcible came
onto the stage
miss [ __ ] was riding a one-wheeled
bicycle and juggling balls
miss forcible skipped behind her holding
a basket of flowers
she scattered the flower petals across
the stage as she went
they reached the front of the stage and
miss [ __ ] leaped nimbly off the
unicycle
and the two old women bowed low all the
dogs stumped their tails and barked
enthusiastically
coraline clapped politely
then they unbuttoned their fluffy round
coats and opened them
but their coats weren't all that opened
their faces open
too like empty shells and out of the
empty
fluffy round body stepped two young
women
they were thin and pale and quite pretty
and had black button eyes
the new miss [ __ ] was wearing green
tights and high brown boost that went
most of the way up her legs
the new miss forcible wore a white dress
and had flowers in her long yellow hair
coraline pressed back against her seat
miss [ __ ] went off the stage and the
noise of trumpets squealed as the
gramophone needle dug its way across the
record and was pulled off
this is my favorite bit whispered the
little dog in the seat next to her
the other misforcible picked a knife out
of a box on the corner of the stage
is this a dagger that i see before me
she asked
yes shatter all the little dogs it is
miss forcible curtsied and all the dogs
applauded again
coraline didn't bother clapping this
time
miss [ __ ] came back on she slapped her
thigh and all the little dogs woofed
and now miss spinks said miriam and i
proudly present a new and exciting
addendum to our theatrical exposition
do i see a volunteer the little dog
nestor coraline nudged her with its
front
paw that's you it hissed
coraline stood up and walked up the
wooden steps to the stage
can i have a big round of applause for
the young volunteer asked miss [ __ ]
the dogs woofed and squealed and thumped
their tails on the velvet seats
now coraline said miss [ __ ] what's your
name coraline
said coraline and we don't know each
other do we
coraline looked at the thin young woman
with black button eyes
and shook her head slowly now
said the other miss [ __ ] stand over
here
she led coraline over to a board by the
side of the stage and put a balloon on
top of coraline's head
miss [ __ ] walked over to miss forcible
she blindfolded miss forcible's button
eyes with a black scarf
and put the knife into her hands then
she turned her round
three or four times and pointed her at
coraline
coraline held her breath and squeezed
her fingers into two tight fists
miss forcible threw the knife at the
balloon it popped loudly and the knife
stuck into the board just above
coraline's head
and twang there coraline breathed out
the dogs went wild miss [ __ ] gave
coraline a very small box of chocolates
and thanked her for being such a good
sport coraline went back to her seat
you were very good said the little dog
thank you sid coraline miss forcible and
miss [ __ ] began juggling with huge
wooden clubs
coraline opened the box of chocolates
the dog looked at them longingly
would you like one she asked the little
dog
yes please whisper the dog only not
toffee ones they make me drool
i thought chocolates weren't very good
for dogs she said
remembering something misforcible had
once told her
maybe where you come from whispered the
little dog here it's all we eat
coraline couldn't see what the
chocolates were in the dark
she took an experimental bite of one
which turned out to be coconut
carline didn't like coconut she gave it
to the dog
thank you said the dog you're welcome
said coraline
miss forcible and miss [ __ ] were doing
some acting miss forcible was sitting on
a stepladder and miss [ __ ] was standing
at the bottom
what's in a name asked miss forcible
that which we call a rose by any other
name would smell as sweet
have you got any more chocolates said
the dog
coraline gave the dog another chocolate
i know not how to tell thee who i am
said miss [ __ ] to miss forcible this
bit finishes soon
whispered the dog then they start folk
dancing
how long does this go on for ask
coraline the theater
all the time said the dog forever and
always
here said coraline keep the chocolates
thank you said the dog coraline stood up
see you soon said the dog bye said
coraline
she walked out of the theater and back
into the garden she had to blink her
eyes at the daylight
her other parents were waiting for her
in the garden standing side by side
they were smiling did you have a nice
time
asked her other mother it was
interesting said coraline
the three of them walked back up to
coraline's other house together
coraline's other mother stroke
coraline's hair with her long white
fingers
coraline shook her head don't do that
said coraline her other mother took her
hand away
so said her other father do you like it
here
i suppose said coral line it's much more
interesting than at home
they went inside i'm glad you like it
said coraline's mother because we'd like
you to think that this is your home
you can stay here forever and always if
you want to
hmm said coraline she put her hand in
her pockets
and thought about it her hand touched
the stone that the real mrs [ __ ] and
forcible had given her the day before
the stone with a hole in it if you want
to stay
said her other father there's only one
little thing we'll have to do so you can
stay here forever and always
they went into the kitchen on a china
plate
on the kitchen table was a spool of
black cotton
and a long silver needle and beside them
two large black buttons
i don't think so said coraline oh but we
want you to set her other mother
we want you to stay and it's just a
little thing
it won't hurt said her other father
caroline knew that when grownups told
you something wouldn't hurt it almost
always did she shook her head
her other mother smiled brightly and the
hair on her head drifted like plants
under the sea
we only want what's best for you she
said
she put her hand on coraline's shoulder
coraline backed away
i'm going now said coraline she put her
hands in her pockets
her fingers closed around the stone with
a hole in it
her other mother's hand scuttled off a
coraline shoulder like a frightened
spider
if that's what you want she said yes
said coraline
we'll see you soon though said her other
father when you come back
um said coraline and then we'll all be
together as one big happy family
said her other mother forever and always
coraline backed away she turned and
hurried into the drawing room and pulled
open the door in the corner
there was no brick wall there now just
darkness a night black
underground darkness that seemed as if
things in it might be moving
coraline hesitated she turned back
her other mother and her other father
were walking toward her holding hands
they were looking at her with their
black button eyes or at least she
thought they were looking at her she
couldn't be sure
her other mother reached out her free
hand and beckoned gently with
one white finger her pale lips mouthed
come back soon although she said nothing
allowed
coraline took a deep breath and stepped
into the darkness where strange voices
whispered and distant winds howled
she became certain that there was
something in the dark behind her
something
very old and very slow her heart beat so
hard and so
loudly she was scared it would burst out
of her chest she closed her eyes against
the dark
eventually she bumped into something and
opened her eyes startled
she had bumped into an armchair in her
drawing room
the open doorway behind her was blocked
by rough red bricks
she was home
you